hey everyone in today's video I'm going
to be asking Tech employees whether they
think artificial intelligence will
replace their jobs I'm at a Tech
Conference in Sydney Australia and I'm
super excited to hear what people have
to say let's go
so first question is what is your name
your role and how long have you been
working in Tech Hello Lucy I'm Chung Vu
I've been in tech for more than 20 years
and I am a principal architect at AWS
what are your thoughts on AI and the
recent developments
I think artificial intelligence or AI is
at the Crux of Technology right now it
is similar to the Internet and mobile
when they came in it's so important for
the future but it's still in its infancy
I believe have you been using tools like
charging BT other AI tools yeah
generative AI like chat gbt has been out
there and off experimented myself it's
the stability diffusion is another tool
I've been using to generate images it is
quite interesting on how much it can do
for us now but like I said I think it's
still in its infancy and over the years
it will improve do you think AI will be
replacing your job in the near future
that's a difficult question for myself
because what I'm doing is not unique to
other roles that other people are doing
but I believe that there'll be a point
in time where AI possibly can do the job
that I'm doing but I'm not so afraid of
that because I may be working on other
things that makes sense because AI might
eliminate jobs in the future but it's
going to also introduce many many other
jobs right that's right we hear jobs now
or skills in crop engineering it didn't
exist a few months ago or even years ago
but in the future that may be a role
that someone have as their job creating
the prompts that can get details or
information out of AI so for people
looking to
looking Tech is it still a career path
you'd read
absolutely I started in Tech when we
didn't have the internet now we've got
the internet and at that time when we
didn't have the internet people were
worried that the internet would take
away their jobs and take away what they
do but actually it created more jobs and
I believe that AI would do the same
thing it would create jobs that we don't
know that we need yet so Duke Energy
Tech it will change and you will get a
role if you're interested do you think
there'll be some roles that will be
automated and replaced by AI I believe
that ultimately AI will be able to do
things that we can do now but the him in
psyche is still very different we're
unpredictable we do things that AI
cannot do yet So eventually yes but it's
a long long time away still and what
advice would you have for people who are
worried that AI might potentially
replace their jobs if you are worried
what you can do is understand what AI
can do and see how you can participate
and contribute to that that would then
Safeguard Your Role because you may be
able to change to another role that is
very beneficial and is working with AI
rather than against AI awesome thanks so
much Sean for your time today thank you
Lucy what is your name your role and how
long have you been working in Tech so my
name is Michael Walmsley my role I work
for Accenture as a serverless enabler
and I've been working in tech for 30
years so what are your thoughts on AI
and the future of generative Ai and
chair GPT well
that's interesting
AI in my opinion right now I think we're
getting very little out of AI today
we're getting categorization we're
getting statistical analysis I think
that's as far as we're going today
generative AI is once the hype dies down
I feel they've got real value if we
train it with with our own data and our
own Enterprise data we can get real
value on power out of generative AI in
my opinion I'm excited by that what are
some ways you've been using AI in your
daily work so in my daily work I
actually work um alexand
so we build artificial intelligence
operational software which is kind of
scary when you combine that with AI
we're generally using it for
categorization we do sentiment analysis
of emails and we also do normally
detection through monitoring metrics of
alerts do you think AI will be replacing
jobs in Tech anytime soon having work in
AI Ops where we do automation of
operational concerns AI is already
starting to replace low-level jobs and I
think anybody who's doing a job that's
simple and repetitive and can be
automated I think that's the risk today
anywhere that we need to have real
decisions made or or real thought put
behind the task that's where AI is not
going to work for us AI is very simple
and what it does and it's got to be
reliable and I think that's a that's the
fear we have today with AI and machine
learning so what do you see AI going in
the next five to ten years given where
it's come throughout my career I think
generative AI is going to really
accelerate the the game that AI is
playing I think that's exciting where's
it going to go in five to ten years I I
don't think we'll get to sentience I
hope we don't but as I build autonomous
software where I can go it's kind of
kind of um freaky when you think about
it to be honest so for those who are
looking to get into Tech do you think
it's your viable career path given the
recent advancements I think so I think
it's a real it's a real place where I
think we need more people more humans
involved in making decisions the more
diverse people we can get get into the
advancement of AI the better AI is
actually going to get so I think it's a
real growing area data analysis and
artificial intelligence machine learning
I think they're the key Technologies the
next five to ten years what is your name
your role and how long have you been
working in Tech my name's Anne-Marie
cherish I'm the director of quality
engineering at Cultura and I have been
in tech for longer years than you have
been on this planet so you must have
seen a lot of tech advancements Tech
changes the whole Industries are
shifting and speaking of that what are
your thoughts on AI and where do you see
AI in the future
um yeah that's that's definitely the new
kid on the Block it gives us so much
potential to do new things but it will
never really replace human beings well
not yet anyway I think we're safe there
for a while there are some things that
AI will be really really useful for and
it's going to be another tool in our
tool set but at this point in time it's
not going to replace anyone's job we
really need smart people people who are
prepared to tackle those problems that
we really want to solve in our world
today and Technology can help us solve
those problems have you been using AI
recently for example charging Beauty and
what are your thoughts on it okay you
know what I love more than chat GPT cat
GPT
it's totally hilarious tell us more
about it okay you just ask any question
and the cat tells you meow meow meow
it's like perfect
but no seriously yeah I use chat GPT use
it to help me create a python script the
other day just to get the basics down
and then you know that you can use that
framework to to help you get started so
there are some people I talk to who are
quite early on in their career and
deciding whether or not they should get
into Tech and a lot of questions I get
asked these days is should I even bother
getting into tag or Cloud if it might
replace my job what are your thoughts on
that and would you still encourage
people to start a career in Tech I mean
if you love Tech and you're excited by
Tech you should just give it a go
Nothing in life gives youthful answers
you're never going to be 100 sure
whether it's the right thing but that's
part of life life is about trying things
out giving it a go seeing if it works
out and letting it take you down a path
that you maybe never imagined it was
going to take you before there's so many
options that Tech will lead you to that
you can't even imagine right now so just
do it exactly right like I started off
in Tech and now I'm making YouTube
videos it's just that's part that's what
living's about right and that's what
we're giving it a go and yeah you'll
learn lots of things and life's exciting
when you do that are there any jobs you
think could potentially be replaced by
AI in the near future I think all those
that are heavily repetitive type jobs
you know yes the jobs that require a
huge amount of human involvement are
going to be much much harder to replace
there are some elements of programming
that AI is going to be able to support
and do but it's never at the end of the
day going to be able to help you
understand some of the core elements of
tech the ability to communicate the
ability to collaborate these are really
important things like we need these to
build Tech and we need a diversity of
perspectives I think for now at the
moment Tech we're we're still okay I
think so too all right thanks so much
Amber for your time today yeah yeah I
know thanks very much Lucy you're the
best what is your name your role and how
long have you been working in Tech hi
everyone I'm Naomi I'm I've been working
the tech industry for over three years
now and I'm an aaml specialist at Amazon
web services so first question I have is
since you're an AIML specialist what
sort of Trends have you been seeing in
the AI space a few Trends I've been
seeing is that AI has been democratized
across a lot of developers across all
Industries as well with the rise of
charge EBT we've seen that AIML has been
you know a dinner table conversation now
it's not just for the CEOs or ctOS or
even the developers which are in AIML
space my mum and dad are talking about
AIML now so it's been a big it's been a
big shift over the last few months so
how have you seen people use chat gbt
and other AI tools recently the main way
that people have been using it is to
improve their productivity to save them
time even you know to help with writer's
block so if someone's not sure how to
start a paragraph to get you started and
even in areas of social media as we've
all seen or in the design space and in
copywriting I think another question I
have is do you think AI could
potentially replace jobs in the future I
think definitely potentially it will
disrupt the workforce and the landscape
of employment dramatically the world
economic Forum in 2020 predicted that 85
million jobs will be displaced however
97 million jobs will be created by 2025
and it just shows the way that AIML will
be transforming the employment landscape
roles that we have never even imagined
of in the next few years will come about
because of AI it's not just a technical
space that will be affected so there's
big opportunities out there which is
quite exciting to me what are some ways
you think people could upskill and learn
about AI talking to different people in
different Generations is actually an
interesting way of learning more I think
as you know the younger Generations more
up to date with technology it's great to
learn from them it's also great to learn
from those who have seen the
transformation from a bigger picture
bigger scale over the last few years
just being curious and reading more
about the changes that are to come with
AIML one question I get asked is is it
even worth it to get to tag or Cloud
that's something a lot of job Seekers
are wondering because they see that
charging PT for example can now write
code but what are your thoughts on this
do you think it can completely replace
the job or these jobs will still be
around for the near future I think there
will always be a human element to
technology and it's really important to
make sure that we have responsible AI as
well especially in the AI space
so I don't think that you should be
deterred by joining tech industry we're
just getting started and it's going to
become a much more widely adopted area
as Enterprises adopt AI so it's a great
time to get involved now I wouldn't be
deterred what do you think are some new
jobs that will pop up with the rise of
AI some of the neurals that I think will
come about would be things like AI
policy in terms of governance regulation
risk mitigation and then I think
there'll be a increased need around
developers in the AI space data
Engineers data scientists they'll be the
ones that are developing these EML
software's applications if you see
there's a gap there's always an
opportunity for you to invent your own
role thanks so much for your time today
Naomi thank you so much for having me as
well what is your name your role and how
long have you been working in Tech my
name is Le Sith I'm a devops engineer at
Reese group I've been working in it for
just about a year now so really fresh to
Enterprise I.T and have you been using
Chachi BT and AI recently what are your
thoughts on it I haven't done a deep
dive into it but I've kind of played
around with it for like small queries
and like little side projects would you
see AI replacing your job in the near
future in my opinion so I work in devops
and one of my core responsibilities is
responding to production incidents and
something that you cannot replace is
being able to talk to an engineer to
kind of get a clear assessment of what
the issue is what's the status of the
investigation speaking from a devops
perspective there's a lot of work that
needs to be done from AI to be able to
have that level of response and
reliability and Trust I think that's a
really big thing that needs to be
discussed can it be trusted by upper
levels of management to provide reliable
information would you see some jobs
being more affected by AI compared to
others you know what that's a really
interesting question like there are
certain you know sectors of fields that
are going to be replaced one thing that
I'd be on the lookout for is testing
like testing is something they're like
dedicated testing engineers that like do
exist and the ability to chat GPT for
you to be able to put a function in and
for it to generate a bunch of unit tests
based off that I'd be kind of concerned
if you have a highly specialized role
that can be replaced you've got to be
really careful not to just be like no
I'm not going to be replaced I think you
just got to understand that these are
really impressive tools you just got to
learn to adopt them as part of your you
know workflow and don't be that person
that's like I'm not going to get
replaced and then get to Broadway so
where do you see AI going in the next
five to ten years so I think one of the
current bottlenecks that Ai and its
consumption within Enterprise I.T is the
fact that we we have a single model
right now that's being used by a global
Community that's kind of limiting
adoption because a lot of companies are
hesitant to use these models that are
going to be sharing data with the wider
Community I foresee a future where this
can be like chat if it is specific to
each kind of company yeah it might be
just a race to see who can develop the
best model who can put the most amount
of data into it almost click it's gonna
be like an arms race basically but just
uh chat gbt models so for people who are
wired about Ai and charging PT replacing
their jobs what advice would you have
for them I would personally recommend
trying to understand your current role
and what parts of it can be replaced by
AI it's all about understanding your
personal weaknesses and upskilling in
that kind of Department continuous
learning exactly all right thanks so
much for your time today thank you very
much Lucy what is your name your role
and how long have you been working in
Tech my name is Samuel uebroy I work as
a partner manager across ANZ for the
cloud security providers look at Palo
Alto networks and been in the industry
for just over five years now what are
your thoughts on charge EBT and AI have
you tried some of those tools yourself
oh my God yes I have yeah I've used it
for writing poems I've used it as a
itinerary planner for my trips so I find
it super helpful and I definitely think
it's going to pick up I see replacing a
lot of things I think if you look at
retail now if you look at technology we
see it you see it picking up in pretty
much every industry right so as a
partner manager have you been using it
in your day-to-day tasks or can you see
EI it potentially streamlining some of
the work that you currently do I
definitely think it's going to
streamline a lot of the work in terms of
automating I do think however some of
those roles that require face-to-face
human interaction it can't replace like
education what advice would you have for
people who are kind of scared of what AI
would bring to the future of jobs I
think embrace it I think it has a use
for everyone no matter what you work in
whether it be retail whether it be
technology whether it be banking it has
a way of being used for appropriate
purposes I mean you look at hospitals in
rural that never had access to
technology or artificial intelligence
which is now it's really helping you
know in surgeries we have people joining
from the states that are performing
virtual surgeries now so I definitely
think embrace it and use it for what it
can be useful but it applies to everyone
and I think I can't think of a single
industry where it's not useful what is
your name your role and how long have
you been working in Tech I'm David I'm A
Cloud engineer and I've been working in
tech for four years cool okay so what
are your thoughts on the future of AI do
you think it's going to be replacing
jobs
um maybe not replacing jobs but I think
it would be like a big part of like some
jobs like in the future especially like
engineering ones do you think a cloud
engineer role could be potentially
replaced by AI
um it's a scary thought possibly but I
feel like AI can never like do the job
like a hundred percent of the time at
least like currently what is important
for now is that it gives like Good
Foundations like it feels like the
building blocks it's like a great tool
to use so far so yeah I'm not worried
but it is scary to think about sometimes
as much as AI can do right now and like
as powerful as it is you can never
really replace I guess like the
decision-making um process and in GMT
you do need to know like it's like what
questions to ask or like what problem
statement or design decision you're
trying to solve in order for like AI to
be effective with it right so I think
those skills do come from like learning
in Tech and like really being Hands-On
in Tech because without implementation
doing things like by yourself you can
never really like learn it truly like
what a solution does and it actually be
treated more as like a tool to help you
do the job rather than like it does the
complete job work for you yeah I agree
completely a lot of people I talked to
today they were calling AIS at all the
personal assistant but not really as
something you should be competing with
or something that would potentially take
over the whole job at least offer now
yeah definitely agreed
foreign